FEMALE SPEAKER: Good
afternoon.
I'm delighted to welcome Chris
Kimball to Google.
I'm sure he needs no
introduction, so I'm going to
do a very brief one.
He's the founder of "Cook's
Illustrated" magazine.
It was founded back in 1980.
And he's the host of "America's
Test Kitchen,"
which is the most watched
cooking show on public TV.
And he's made so many
contributions to the culinary
industry that I'm not even going
to try to mention them.
But he did found Who's Who
and Cooking in America.
And at least in my kitchen,
"America's Test Kitchen"
cookbooks are a must have.
And Chris is here today to talk
about "The Science of
Good Cooking." If you haven't
picked up your copy in the
back, please do.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRIS KIMBALL: It feels
like the "Johnny
Carson Show" or something.
So this is a little
bit about--
I won't talk too much about the
book, but about what we do
in "The Test Kitchen." You know,
the fundamental precept
of science is you sit around
and think about why things
happen, and then you devise an
experiment to either prove or
disprove that.
So you watch the apple
fall, whatever.
And the ultimate example
of this--
there's a YouTube video
about this, actually.
It's about 40 minutes long.
It's great.
A called Lawrence Krauss,
cosmologist, and he decided,
with a bunch of other
cosmologists a few years ago,
to figure out whether
we live in a closed,
open, or flat universe.
This will have something to do
with cooking, eventually.
So in a closed universe, it
collapses, we have a big bang,
we all die.
In open universe, it expands
exponentially.
In a flat universe, it expands,
but the rate of
expansion slows.
So they were trying to
figure out how to do
that relatively simply.
And so the first thing they
said, well, OK, in a flat
universe, light travels
in a straight line.
In a closed or open universe,
light diverges or converges.
Which means that if you looked
at something a long way from
Earth, it would be bigger or
smaller than it actually is.
If you live in a flat
universe, it will
be the right size.
OK, so the next thing
was what to measure.
Well, they said, let's go as far
away from Earth as we can,
because the farther away we
are, the more we could see
that converging or diverging
of the light.
Let's go back to the Big Bang,
13.72 billion years ago.
The problem with that is, for
about 100,000 years after the
Big Bang, it was like looking
at the center of the sun.
It was pea soup.
Couldn't see anything.
So about 100,000 years later,
you could start to see things.
And so, OK, that's
a good distance.
Now the question was, what
are you going to measure?
And here's where it got
a little weird.
They said, well, the universe
is only 100,000 years old.
Nothing travels faster than
the speed of light.
So that includes gravity.
Gravity can't travel faster
than the speed of light.
So the biggest thing could be
100,000 light years, because
if you're a lump of matter,
you want to attract other
matter, you couldn't communicate
farther than that.
It's like a little town in
Germany 2,000 years ago, a
village that maybe people from
20 or 30 miles might come in,
but if you're 500 miles away,
you wouldn't even know the
village existed.
Same thing.
So they said, OK, so the
object would be there.
We know where it's going
to be, how far away.
And it should be 100,000
light years.
That's the maximum size, which
turns out to be 1 degree of
360 in the sky.
So the other question is,
how do you measure it?
And they said, well, we'll
send up a balloon.
This is what I like, these
guys sit around trying to
figure out what kind
of universe.
They get this big helium
balloon, they send it up and
it has essentially a camera that
measures the background
microwave radiation
from that point.
Light waves as they travel,
flatten out, infrared,
microwaves have the longest
wavelength.
So for those of you-- and there
aren't many of you here.
There's a few of my vintage--
in the days a television station
stopped broadcasting,
oddly enough, at 1:00 or 2:00
in the morning, you'd get
static on your television set.
And 1% of that static was, in
fact, microwave radiation from
just after the Big Bang.
So you could actually see it.
So they took pictures, and they
developed it, and they
put it up on the wall.
And it turns out that the
biggest things they saw were
exactly 1 degree.
And that was exactly
what was predicted.
And so since it was 1 degree,
we live in a flat universe.
So that's exactly what we do at
"America's Test Kitchen."
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
CHRIS KIMBALL: See?
On a slightly smaller scale.
So we don't have big balloons.
But we use scientific
principles.
Equilibrium.
This was invented or discovered
about 1750 in France.
French scientists decided,
well, OK, I don't have
balloons, but I have
pig bladders.
I'll fill it with alcohol, put
it in a big tub of water, and
I'll see what happens.
Well, of course, what happened
was water is 100% water,
alcohol is 50% water, so some of
the water from outside went
through the membrane to
create equilibrium.
That's called osmosis.
Diffusion.
But if you're going to brine a
turkey next week, there's a
little osmosis there.
Salt.
You put salt on the outside of
a turkey, or in a brine, and
that's diffusion.
The salt from the outside goes
to the inside to create
equilibrium.
So when you brine, you're using
a very old scientific
concept of equilibrium.
And what happens is the chicken
or the turkey soaks up
water, and if there was no
brine, there was no salt, that
water would come out
during cooking.
But what the salt does is it
takes the proteins, it
denatures them, they are able
to now hold onto water,
because there's now
room for water to
get into the proteins.
Some of the proteins turn
into a gelatin,
which also absorb water.
So what the salt does is help
the turkey hold onto water,
even when heated and roasted.
So not all of it leaves.
Some of it actually stays.
And that's all based
on an old premise.
Some of the things we like
to do is disprove
stupid cooking theories.
The world is flat theories.
One of them is sear meat
to seal in the juices.
You still in cookbooks today,
and on some cooking shows,
will see people say that, and
it's just total nonsense.
Searing meat sears meat.
It's the Maillard
reaction, which
we'll get to in a second.
Amino acids and sugars are
creating flavor compounds.
But it turns out that juicy
meat is just a function of
internal temperature.
About 110 degrees, meat fibers
that sort of look like
insulated wires will start to
shrink around the diameter and
the length.
The liquid in those fibers
gets pushed out.
The more you cook meat, the
dryer it gets, and it has
nothing to do with whether
it's seared or not.
If you pot roast or barbecue,
and you start with a piece of
meat that has a lot of collagen
in it, like pork
butt, for example, well, that
collagen turns into gelatin,
melts, and that will hold onto
liquid, so that does work over
a long period of time.
Another thing people say very
often is braising turns out
moist, succulent meat.
And it kind of makes sense,
because you have a closed pot,
and you have a little bit of
liquid, and you have a pot
roast or piece of pork.
In fact, Madeleine Kamman, in
"The Making of a Cook," which
is a great book you should read,
says that very thing.
She says the steam gets
into the meat.
It does this.
No.
It's the same thing.
You can boil a pot roast, or
simmer a pot roast in water.
You can roast it
in a dry oven.
You can braise it in
a closed container.
And if you get it to the same
internal temperature, 185,
190, it will be exactly
the same inside.
So it doesn't matter if there's
liquid around it, air
around it, a little bit of
liquid on it, steam, it
doesn't matter.
It's all about the internal
temperature.
Lots of other things--
recipes say pat meat dry
before you sautee it.
And, by the way, I know what
you all do, even though you
work for Google.
I know what you do.
And that is that you
take our recipes--
and I do the same thing--
and you take them as vague
directions about what you
might do if you actually
had the ingredients.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
CHRIS KIMBALL: And you don't,
and you don't have the right
cookware, and lots
of other things.
So our job is not to create
a recipe that
works in our kitchen.
It's for us to figure
out what you do.
And what you do is really
interesting.
And matter of fact, I think
behavioral psychology should
spend more time looking at--
they do, like, how
people vote.
Now they should do
how people cook.
About two years ago, we had a
chicken breast recipe, and we
sent our recipes out.
It takes us five or six weeks
to develop a recipe.
We sent it out to a bunch of you
who volunteered, and over
the course of a week, 200 or 300
of you will have made the
recipe, and you'll
fill out a form.
And unless 80% of you say you
would make it again, we go
back in the kitchen.
Well, this particular
gentleman--
and this recipe got
a great rating.
90% of the people would
make it again.
This one gentleman said it was
the worst chicken breast
recipe he'd ever made, which
caught our attention.
And at the bottom, there's a
little place on SurveyMonkey,
which is the software we use--
he had a comment, and this is
verbatim, what he said.
He said, "Well," comma, "I
didn't have any chicken."
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
CHRIS KIMBALL: OK.
"I substituted shrimp."
AUDIENCE: [GASPS]
CHRIS KIMBALL: So if you cook
shrimp for 25 minutes, indeed,
it would be the worst shrimp
recipe you've ever had.
But it's my fault, see.
So it was my job to say in the
head note, do not substitute
shrimp for chicken in this
chicken breast recipe.
So anyway, to go back to the
steak story, so the problem
is, if you put a wet piece of
meat or poultry in a pan,
assuming the pan is the right
temperature, the meat's not
going to get above the boiling
point of water, because the
water has to evaporate first.
So your steak is sitting there
at 210 or 212 degrees until
that water goes away.
So you're steaming the meat,
it sticks to the pan.
The Maillard reaction, which as
I said is amino acids and
sugars creating flavor
compounds, doesn't happen 'til
over 300 degrees, so you're not
going to get any browning.
And that is a reason, by the
way, you shouldn't use
non-stick cookware-- because
70% of cookware sold in the
United States is non-stick.
It's good for eggs,
it's good for
seafood, a few other things.
Stir fry with a sticky sauce.
It's terrible for everything
else, because you can't create
a fond on the bottom of the
pan-- that brown stuff that
when you're first beginning to
cook, you throw away, because
it's messy, and then you realize
it has all the flavor.
Years ago, a friend of mine
came over from France--
he was a butcher--
to show us some tricks.
And during the morning, he had a
bunch of onions, like 5 or 6
pounds of onions, a little
wine, little
water, little oil.
All he did was put it in a big
Le Creuset Dutch oven, and he
sauteed it, browned it,
caramelized it.
And every half hour or so, he
deglazed the bottom of the pot
with a little wine.
And he didn't add stock,
he didn't add any other
ingredients.
And by 12:00, 12:30, we had
French onion soup, and it was
the best French onion soup
I had in my life.
And all the flavor, 100% of it,
came from the fond at the
bottom of the pan.
And so if that had been a
non-stick pan, we would have
had the world's worst
French onion soup.
So anyway.
So those are just a few of
the things that we test.
And another one which is
relevant for next week, for
those of you who are going to
make pie dough, recipes always
say add just enough water 'til
the dough holds together.
Yeah, whoever wrote that should
be taken out and run
over with a truck, because
you're all scared to add too
much water, so what happens?
You create dry pie dough,
and it doesn't roll out.
It rolls out into pieces, and
you have to do a pat in the
pan crust when nobody's
looking.
That's what's going to
happen, because I've
done it many times.
And the reason you don't want
to add too much water is
because in flour, there
are two proteins--
glutinin, which sounds like
gluten, but it's different,
and gliadin.
In the presence of water, they
form gluten, and that's why
you could have a no knead bread
dough recipe-- because
if you let water and flour sit
long enough, like overnight,
gluten will develop
on its own.
You don't have to knead bread.
So what's going on with pie
pastry is, a little too much
water, a little bit too much
gluten gets developed.
So we sat around, just like
Lawrence Krauss did years ago,
and said, we need more liquid,
but we can't use water,
because water reacts with
glutinin and gliadin to
produce gluten.
What else could we use?
And the obvious answer
was vodka.
I mean, really.
Because alcohol actually doesn't
react with proteins.
Water does.
So we said, we'll use half
water, half vodka, add a
little bit of extra liquid--
another tablespoon, so you
have a nice, moist dough,
rolls out easily.
And by the way, alcohol will
dissipate at a much lower
temperature than water, so you
put in the oven, and you end
up with a nice, dry, flaky
dough, so, vodka pie crust.
And thank you to our
food scientist.
One thing I should warn you
about food scientists, because
I've worked with them
all my life.
We have a guy who works
with us, this guy,
Crosby, who's very good.
But remember in fifth grade, you
had those stupid molecular
things with the balls?
Well, eventually, over time,
I kept asking, do molecules
really look like this?
And some would say,
well, not really.
It's just, we're trying to--
I paraphrase--
we're giving you as much
information as we think you
can handle.
So great.
They think I'm an idiot.
So over all these years, I'm
thinking about these red balls
and green balls and
everything else.
And yes, it talks about
connectivity and other things,
but it is, in essence,
really, molecules
don't look like that.
So when you talk to a food
scientist, the first time you
ask them a question about
starchy potatoes, for example,
and amylose and amylopectin and
everything else, they'll
give you the answer they think
you can handle, which is
basically the idiot's answer.
And then you come back a couple
weeks later and say,
well, you know, it doesn't
really make sense because--
and they say, OK, OK,
now I'll tell you.
And then they give you
the next layer down.
There's like 10 layers, and I'm
working my way down to the
10th layer.
I'm at about layer 7 now,
because he thinks I can
handle layer 7.
But the problem with food
science is, as Einstein, of
course, was not a food
scientist-- it was too hard--
there are too many variables.
There's too much
stuff going on.
So it's very hard to
isolate one thing.
Even if you isolate, let's say,
10% protein flour from
12%, you do two cakes or two
biscuits, it could be that you
didn't measure something
properly, the ovens were
slightly off, it was a humid
day versus not a humid day.
So there's lots of stuff going
on, so you have to do things
over and over and over again to
make sure that your results
actually are reproducible,
which, of course, is the
essence of science.
So that's what we do, and this
book is really a result of 20
years of work in the kitchen.
We took 50 scientific principles
in some recipes to
illustrate them.
And I've been on tour, and one
of the things I do if it's a
morning show or something is we
have a red bliss potato, a
non-starchy potato, and we
have a russet potato.
The russet potato has more
starch, which has got a higher
specific gravity, and should
sink, and the red bliss potato
should float.
And I did this on "The Today
Show" about a month ago, and
they both sank.
So sometimes, the results
are not reproducible.
So I just hid it behind
the other thing, and
it just went on.
So that's what we do, and I'd
love to take some questions.
And by the way, before someone
has the courage to ask a
question, Lynne Rossetto Casper
from "The Splendid
Table," whom I've known for
a long time, she had this
problem once, and she told the
audience that she would start
removing her clothes if she
didn't get a question asked.
And they started asking
questions.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
So I was wondering two things.
One of them is that you
mentioned caramelizing onions.
And I know that what Einstein
told his cook-- that was one
of the author's pet peeves.
CHRIS KIMBALL: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: That's a side thing.
You can talk.
But the question I
have is actually
about non-stick cookware.
CHRIS KIMBALL: That
was Wolke, yeah.
That guy.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
The question I have is actually
about non-stick cookware.
There's actually new non-stick
cookware coming out.
It's ceramic, I guess, base,
or something else.
Can you talk a little bit about
what you think of those?
CHRIS KIMBALL: Yeah,
we've tested a lot
of non-stick cookware.
There's low-stick cookware like
Calphalon, which, if you
look at it under a microscope,
it just has
fewer craters in it.
It's smoother, so the food
doesn't stick as much.
There are ceramic non-stick
cookware as well.
We basically didn't
like any of them.
They either claimed they were
greener, which they really
weren't, or if they
really were green,
they weren't non-stick.
So we went through all of them,
and the one that we
ended up with is just
the classic.
They all use essentially the
same chemical-- slightly
different bonding techniques.
The problem with non-stick
cookware--
there's a number of them--
first of all, there's something
called polymer fume
fever, and I actually subjected
myself to this just
to find out what it was like.
So over 500 degrees, you'll see
the smoking, and if you
happen to have a parakeet in
the room, you know, the
parakeet might not survive
that process.
I took a big whiff, and had a
vicious headache for about
five hours.
Over 600 degrees, that chemical
actually starts to
break down, and that's
why non-stick pans,
over a year or two--
I mean, in our kitchen, they
don't last more than a year.
They actually start to break
down, and that coating
actually comes off.
So the other thing you can use
is cast iron, if you are of
the mind to season it properly,
which takes a little
more time, which I like.
But when it comes to doing
scrambled eggs, a 10-inch or
8-inch non-stick All-Clad or
something similar actually is
fairly essential.
But that's about all
I use it for.
AUDIENCE: I'll say in defense of
non-stick, you guys have a
great recipe from a few months
ago for Thai stir fried
noodles for which you say
specifically, get this
non-stick 12-inch pan.
Great recipe, I love it.
One of the great examples of
I don't do it unless I have
exactly what "Cook's
Illustrated"
says I need to have.
CHRIS KIMBALL: You're the
only reader who does.
I've finally found him.
AUDIENCE: From bitter
experience,
I've learned my lesson.
So my question-- you guys test
all these recipes over and
over again in the "Test
Kitchen." What do you do with
all the food that you create?
CHRIS KIMBALL: Oh, well, first
of all, we're not licensed by
the town of Brookline just
outside of Boston to serve
food to the public.
It's a long story.
So we wanted to give food to the
local shelter, food bank.
We do give canned food, but we
couldn't give our cooked food.
So we have about 140 employees,
slightly smaller
than you, and the test cooks in
the kitchen-- we have about
45 test cooks, it's about a
3,500 square foot kitchen--
the really good food, and the
really expensive food, like
the tenderloin, the lobster,
et cetera--
that immediately disappears.
We have these big clear plastic
takeout containers and
big magic markers.
So I--
Chris, for Chris, put the stuff
in, and go into our
takeout fridge.
And at night, they
bring it home.
The food that's pretty good
but not great, we call the
marketing department
down for that.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
CHRIS KIMBALL: No, I mean,
marketing's important, right?
OK.
And then the really horrible
food is the finance people.
My CFO lives off leftover
Halloween candy until January.
That's all she eats.
And they're grateful for that,
so that's how it works.
We're hoping we can get licensed
to actually do
something else with it.
We have 140 employees, so it all
gets eaten, and our test
cooks never cook during the week
at night, because they've
been cooking all day, and they
just take the food home, so.
AUDIENCE: You brought up the
concept of brining earlier,
and the best Thanksgiving turkey
I ever made I brined.
And could you go over some of
the basic principles, since a
lot of people are going to be
roasting turkeys next week, of
what it takes to make
a good turkey?
CHRIS KIMBALL: Yes.
The problem with having a food
magazine is every year,
there's Thanksgiving,
and we have to come
up with a new recipe.
So somehow we've come
up with 20 versions.
The basic formula is
1 cup of table salt
per gallon of water.
If it's going to be a 12, 14
pound turkey, you'd brine it
for six to eight hours,
something like that, overnight.
You got to keep it cool,
preferably no more than 40
degrees, which can be a problem
if you don't have a
cold cellar somewhere
or outside.
And then you want to make sure
it's dried off very well.
You put it in a 375 to 400 oven,
breast side down for an
hour, then flip it breast side
up and continue cooking it--
maybe even increase the
temperature for the last half
hour or so.
We've done lots of other
recipes, one of which I like
is you cut it into parts
and you braise it.
I did that last year.
Then you get a great gravy out
of it, and then you don't have
the problem with the white meat,
dark meat, when it's
done problem.
I just did for "Morning
Edition" next week on
Wednesday-- we do a segment
every year on Thanksgiving,
and we did Julia Child recipes,
all Julia Child recipes.
She's got this great recipe
where she takes the backbone
out and takes the whole breast
and puts it over a huge amount
of stuffing on a roasting tray
with aluminum foil, cooks
that, and then she has the thigh
and the legs together,
those two pieces roasted
separately on a rack on a
baking sheet.
But what she does is
really interesting.
She takes the bone out
of the thigh, which
takes about a minute.
It's real easy to do.
Just use a paring knife.
And then she spreads it open,
puts salt, pepper, a little
sage, whatever you want, sewed
it up, or just wrapped it
easily with some string
and roasted that.
Only took about an hour
and a half to cook.
And then when you slice
the thigh, there's no
bone, which is great.
And that really works well.
And if you like, she also had a
picture of reassembling the
bird after it's cooked, so you
have that little Norman
Rockwell moment or whatever.
If anyone does have
that moment.
So that's the basic concept.
The other way you can
do it is butterfly a
turkey after brining.
You take the backbone out.
It's good to have poultry
shears for that.
Flatten it, press down on the
breastbone, and then cook that
on a rack over a huge mound of
stuffing, which is also one of
my favorite techniques.
So you don't have to worry about
a little bit of stuffing
in the cavity, which you should
never do, because the
stuffing takes a long time
to get up to 160.
You don't have much of it, and
the meat will be overcooked.
So butterfly it, take the
backbone out, rack over
stuffing, and you get
maximum stuffing.
So those are four suggestions.
AUDIENCE: Did you start
as a food writer?
Was that what you sort of--
CHRIS KIMBALL: I started as
a primitive art major at
Columbia in 1969.
Well, actually, no.
I had four years of the
revolution, so we didn't have
finals three out of the four
years, because the secret was,
we only had revolutions
when it was warm,
which was in May, usually.
So I started that.
I worked in a small publishing
firm in New York for a couple
years, ran a company for a
few years in the '70s.
It was in and around the whole
issue of magazines and
publishing.
And then I started "Cook's"
in 1980--
April 1980.
Today, if you want to--
I've been grandfathered
into my own company.
I don't think I'd get a job
there now, probably.
If you wanted to get a job in
our kitchen today, you'd have
to come in and do a bench test,
which means that a bunch
of people will stand around you
with clipboards and not
talk while you cook all day, to
see if you have the knife
skills, you can expedite.
But really, we're looking for
people who are incredibly
stubborn, don't mind doing the
same thing constantly, like
the same recipe for weeks
and weeks on end.
You have to develop a recipe
on your own and write it up
and submit the article.
And then we do three month
internships, and then usually
at the end of that period, we'll
keep one or two of the
people to work full time
in the kitchen.
So what we really do
is a group process.
We sit down every Tuesday
morning at 9:00 AM, editorial
table, and whoever's working on
a particular recipe talks.
We sit down, have ideas.
Every time there's a tasting,
there's a bunch of people in
the kitchen.
So it's really very much
about a group process.
It's not quite one man, one
vote, but it's almost that.
And that's how we develop
the process.
It comes from--
I went to a high school which
used an oval table, the
Harkness table.
And you'd sit around a table,
and the professor or teacher
would be standing up in the
corner, and you would have to
come up with a position about
something about Russian
history, and you'd have to
defend your position as your
fellow students ripped you to
shreds, which is basically
what we do now is to sit around
and argue, which I
assume you do a lot here, too.
AUDIENCE: So you're in
magazines, but you must also
have been kind of crazy
about food.
And then you also seem to have
this scientific bent.
CHRIS KIMBALL: Well, I've been
cooking since I was about
seven, yes.
My first recipe was a chocolate
cake out of "The Joy
of Cooking" with a seven minute
boiled icing, which
turned out like snot.
Actually, I do still
remember the cake.
Everyone said it was very good,
but I knew it wasn't.
And in the '70s, I
started taking a
lot of cooking classes.
And I realized there was one
guy in particular, who was
actually a great guy,
but he put on
this fake French accent--
he was from Florida.
But he talked like
the [FAKE FRENCH]
like this, and he would say
things like you have to scald
milk to make a bechamel.
Well, I went home, made it with
cold milk, it was fine.
He refused to talk about it.
And it turns out that you only
scald milk if it's raw milk,
because pasteurization is
scalding milk, and you want to
kill off an enzyme
that needs to be
killed to have it thicken.
So it occurred to me, the
emperor's new clothes, that a
lot of stuff that was being
taught at the time in the '60s
and '70s was just being
passed down.
And probably at the time, it
made sense, like when people
had nothing but raw milk.
But there was a whole bunch of
things like that that just
made no sense anymore.
And the cookware was changing,
the food processor came in
from Carl Sontheimer
in the early '70s.
French cooking was going
away, American
cooking was coming up.
So my interest was actually
starting a magazine where you
could talk about cooking.
At the time, there was
"Cuisine," "Food & Wine," "Bon
Apetitt," "Gourmet," none
of which really
focused on the kitchen.
It was all about people
smiling at parties,
traveling, on yachts.
And so I just wanted to focus
on fudgy brownies,
essentially.
AUDIENCE: So you talked about
techniques, but I want to ask
you about the actual product
and ingredients.
I made a conscious decision to
switch to grass-fed beef, and
most of these techniques no
longer work, because this meat
is so different.
There's less fat.
What recommendations,
what suggestions do
you have for me?
CHRIS KIMBALL: Well, we raise
our own beef and pork, too,
and we started out doing
pure grass fed.
Well, I don't know if you've
ever had no grain purely grass
fed, but it's tough
and it's strong.
And actually, in the last
three months, we
grained them, too.
So I like mostly grass fed, but
I like grain at the end,
because I think it's better.
But it's like trying
to cook venison,
because it's very lean.
And the other problem is the
butchers love the round, the
thigh, because it's this huge
hunk of meat with just one
bone in it.
It's not complicated.
But the problem is, it's lean.
And especially grass-fed beef.
So the first thing I would do
is get the fattiest cuts.
Chuck eye roast,
shoulder roast,
anything from the chuck.
I would never touch the round
under any circumstances.
And then, unless you want to
lard it, like Fannie Farmer
used to do, you're probably
going to have to
cook it low and slow.
But I would get the fattiest cut
from grass-fed beef that I
possibly could.
Don't get anything lean,
because it's
going to be lean anyway.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious what your
take is on the molecular
gastronomy movement, which also
sort of bills itself as a
science driven, although
probably not
as accessible, approach.
CHRIS KIMBALL: Well, I'm now an
instant expert, because I
went to see Nathan Myhrvold two
days ago, and his chefs
cooked me a 12-course meal
one afternoon in Seattle.
And first of all, OK,
let me describe.
He has a lab to do a lot
of other things.
The modernist cuisine is
just a small subset.
You walk in.
The place is huge.
It must have 50 $1 million
machines in there to do all
sorts of weird things, like
3D printers and stuff.
So the first thing I walk in is
I see this big HD screen,
and things are popping
on and off.
And I say, what's that?
He said, well, a few years ago,
we decided to solve the
problem of malaria.
OK.
And one of the guys on the team
was one of the guys who
helped develop the Star Wars
project, which actually was
pretty much a failure,
as far as I can tell.
And he said, well, I don't
know, just get a
laser gun and zap them.
And then the guy said to me,
well, at first we thought that
was foolish, comma.
I said, what do you
mean "at first"?
It's like, what, it's
not foolish now?
So he claims--
I didn't believe this-- he
claims that this thing was
actually showing there's
mosquitoes in a glass--
am I losing my voice here?
Hello?
There we are.
He claims that he had this big
glass container, an aquarium
of mosquitoes, and they could
sense the mosquitoes
individually.
That's what was showing
up on the screen.
Then it gets weird.
It says, they can tell the
difference between a male
mosquito and a female
mosquito.
And I said, how do
you do that?
He said, well, female mosquitoes
beat their wings at
a different RPM than
male mosquitoes.
OK.
Female mosquitoes bite,
males don't.
So I said, then what happens?
He said, oh, then the laser gun
melts their wings and they
fall down and die.
I said, OK, so you're in Africa,
Niger, and you have
this $100,000 mosquito
killing laser gun.
Now what are you going to do?
Well, we'd ring the
village with them.
I said, how about like, $1.00
for a mosquito net?
Like, really?
Anyway, so I was going,
like, really?
So anyway, the meal was
fabulous, though.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
CHRIS KIMBALL: And there were
no mosquitoes anywhere.
I mean, he's proven if you're
incredibly smart, and you have
unlimited capital and time,
what you can do to food.
It has no bearing on home
cooking at all.
But, I mean, for example,
the pistachio gelato--
I love pistachio gelato.
I've had it in a lot of
different places.
And most of the time, it's
vanilla ice cream with green
food coloring, essentially,
because it doesn't taste like
pistachio, right?
So this pistachio gelato
was amazing.
I mean, it's like, amazing
pistachio flavor.
And he extracted oil,
and guess what.
Each scoop, which is about this
big, was $25 worth of
pistachios to get one scoop
of pistachio gelato.
The other thing he showed
me-- and they were
great French fries--
but in order to get that crunchy
outside, he puts the
French fries in water--
am I losing my voice again?
I think you have to keep putting
quarters in the thing.
It's a cavitation device,
essentially.
Sonic waves go through the water
and rough up the surface
of the potato.
And so, yeah, it did
work, but he's
extracting maximum flavor.
So the answer is, why not?
Good for him.
He's an interesting guy.
He's rich.
The food was great.
But I don't think anybody here
is going to be making $25 a
scoop pistachio ice cream
anytime soon.
Although maybe some of those
techniques end up in a home
kitchen in 10 years.
I don't know.
But it's not what we do.
What we do is, my premise has
been, most people most of the
time don't have a lot of
success in the kitchen.
It's not necessarily a failure,
but it doesn't turn
out exactly the way you want.
If you were building airplanes,
and 80% of the
time, they fell out of the
sky, you wouldn't be in
business too long.
Recipes, if you think of it as
a business, it's the only
business in the world where you
can actually have a very
high failure rate and
still be around.
And so our thought was, we're
not trying to get you to
modernist cuisine or
French Laundry.
We're just trying to get people
to the point where most
of the time they go in
the kitchen, if they
do follow the recipe--
don't substitute shrimp
for chicken--
it'll turn out well.
And that's all.
We're not trying to
create chefs.
We're just trying to say, you
can be confident, go in the
kitchen, and get pretty
good results.
That's about it.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
For a variety of reasons, my
girlfriend and I only get to
cook it once a week or so.
Do you have any advice for
rewarding but efficient
occasional cooking
at small scale?
CHRIS KIMBALL: Yeah, the best
thing I can say is, 100 years
ago, the Italian grandmother had
a very limited repertoire.
As I was taught to
cook by a baker--
actually, a cook in Vermont--
Vermont!
And I have a recipe card.
She has about 50 recipe cards.
So I think the secret has been
people had a limited
repertoire of foods that were
local with techniques that
were all related, and that's why
they didn't need recipes.
Because your grandmother, if
she cooked, or grandfather,
they had a baking powder biscuit
recipe, or they had a
curry goat recipe.
Whatever it was, they
knew how to do it.
So if you're going to start out
in cooking, and you don't
have a lot of time, my
suggestion is have 25 recipes.
Pick 25 recipes that cover a
braise, or a tagine, or a
stew, or a quick bread, a soda
bread, whatever, and just get
a range of recipes that cover
most of the bases, and get to
the point you don't
need a recipe.
You can make them.
Then you can do anything
you want.
But if you do that, it's great,
because the problem
with all of you and the problem
with me is, on Tuesday
night I'm going oh, I love that
Ottolenghi recipe from
"Plenty" or "Jerusalem." I want
to make that tonight with
the Gorgonzola and the lentils
and the caramelized onions.
And the next night, I'll say,
well, maybe I want something
from South America,
and then I--
well, you never get anywhere,
because you're changing
ingredients and techniques.
So stick to 25 recipes.
The example I like
to give is music.
Like most aging baby
boomers, I have a
Grateful Dead cover band.
Of course, that's typical.
At some point, you all will
have Grateful Dead cover
bands, or something.
Aerosmith.
I don't know, whatever.
So if you've ever seen a
50-year-old pick up a guitar,
it's a disaster because
he or she thinks they
can just play it--
without "Guitar Hero--" play
it, and they can't, because
you actually have to know
something, like there are
chords and scales, and there are
two note chords, and three
note chords, and the triads.
There's the blues scale, and
the pentatonic scale, blah,
blah, blah.
Jerry Garcia, my hero, he played
scales two hours a day.
So there is something to know.
And so by sticking to 25
recipes, you'll actually get
the technique down.
You'll understand something
about cooking, and then you
can do whatever you
want from there.
I always work Jerry Garcia into
every talk, by the way.
AUDIENCE: Question about
your turkey recipes.
They typically deal with
smaller birds, or
medium sized birds.
Do you have ideas on cooking
larger ones, particularly when
you're cooking them upside
down to start?
Is there a limit to how big a
bird you can cook that way?
CHRIS KIMBALL: No.
We usually like 14 to 16 pound
birds, because they, I think,
usually taste better.
But you can get a 22 pounder.
The question is, is your
oven big enough?
And then, of course, you have
a bird that's very hot, and
you have to flip it over
after an hour.
If you do the butterfly
technique, however, you don't
have to flip it.
And if you braise it in parts,
you don't have to flip it.
But if you do the hour down
and then up, you do.
I just use kitchen
towels to do it.
Some of those Orka silicone
mitts and stuff, you ever try
to use those?
Your hands get sweaty,
and then you drop it
anyway, so who cares?
So I just use kitchen
towels and flip it.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My next question is about when
you write up recipes.
It's very clear from anybody
who's read "Cook's" how much
work you guys put into
developing your recipes and
trying out every variation.
Have you had a chance to do
that with how you actually
write up the recipes to present
the information and
help understand what's the
best way to present it to
people such that they're
able to follow it?
CHRIS KIMBALL: Oh, yes.
Yes.
Most of the stories, because
we're dealing with cooks now,
not writers--
most of the people who work for
us don't have any writing
experience, and so the editing
process is tortured.
And we had made people cry
after reading the--
I used to read everything.
I stopped about a year ago.
I read it, but not
at the beginning.
And I used to put comments in.
And my comments were usually
something like, this is the
worst first paragraph I've
ever read in my life.
So what you get is, I remember
my mother, when she used to
make-- and I'd say, look.
Unless you can describe your
mother in some detail and
paint a picture, nobody cares
about your mother.
You have to make us care.
So people take a long time
to get to a point.
I think the issue is, I always
say it's like a Sherlock
Holmes story.
There's the one boot is missing
in "The Hound of the
Baskervilles," you know?
So when you're telling the story
of how you solved the
problem of bad food to get to
good food, it's a mystery.
It's a narrative.
You have to tell a story.
A story has ups and downs,
it has ins and
outs, it has dead ends.
So you have to construct
that story.
The problem is the test cook has
tested in a certain order,
and he or she then thinks, it's
a documentary process of
documenting what they did.
That has nothing
to do with it.
It's about creating a story.
And so even though it doesn't
seem when you read it that
we've done a lot of work, we
spend some time, it's like 50
or 60 hours on the story, to
tell a story, because people
have to care about the story.
Who wants to read 2,000 words
about fudgy brownies unless
you kind of make
it interesting?
And so a lot of the tests
we leave out.
It's like editing a
Hollywood movie.
You've got to cut characters
out and scenes.
It's the same thing.
So it's all about storytelling
and narrative.
And then finally, we call it
the aha moment, when you
finally, what's the big thing
you discovered that made the
recipe work?
And hopefully there's something
interesting.
AUDIENCE: When you were talking
about cooking myths
and how they're not true, you
mentioned searing the meat,
which we've heard from Harold
McGee a couple times.
But you also mentioned
patting the meat try
before you sautee it.
And I don't think you followed
through on why that's a myth.
CHRIS KIMBALL: Well, what I
said was, it's not a myth.
It's something that people tell
you to do, but people
don't do it, because they don't
understand why they
should do it.
And the reason is, as I said,
if you put the meat in a pan
and it's wet, until the water
turns to steam and evaporates,
the surface temperature of the
meat's not going to go over
the boiling point of water.
So all that energy's going
into the water to
turn it into steam.
The energy is not going
into the meat.
So until that happens, you're
sitting there in the pan with
a fairly cool pan.
You're not getting any browning,
you're not getting
any Maillard reaction.
So that's one of those things
you need to do.
What I've discovered is people
won't do what recipes tell you
unless you understand it.
And that was my problem, too.
So we're just trying to explain
in some cases not
necessarily a myth, but we're
trying to explain why you
should do it, and the odds of
you doing it will be greater
if we explain it.
AUDIENCE: It's not because the
water will spatter in the oil
and get you burned?
CHRIS KIMBALL: That would
be true, too, and yes.
And the other thing is that if
it's wet, the chicken skin
will stick irretrievably
to the bottom of
the skillet, yes.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So among all of the home cooks
that you've interacted with
and sampled, what's the single
way in which they've most
tragically underinvested in
their home equipment, whether
it's getting something lame that
they should get a good
version of it?
CHRIS KIMBALL: Three things.
The first is an instant read
thermometer that really works.
The only one we really love
is the Thermapen.
It's $95.
It's obscenely expensive,
but it really works.
It takes a temperature from the
end of the probe, not an
inch or two up, so you know
exactly what you're measuring.
It has a big readout display.
It's instant.
I could cook without it,
but it would be hard.
I bake bread.
American bread is 190 to 195,
European bread 205 for
custards, et cetera.
Two, a knife.
Forschner makes a Victorinox
Fibrox knife.
It's $25.
It beats the $150 knives
all the time.
Third thing is knife
sharpening.
Jacques Pepin would die if I
said, go buy an electric knife
sharpener, but go buy an
electric knife sharpener.
The Chef's Choice model
130, 140 works great.
There's no other way to sharpen
a knife at home unless
you really want to stand there
for 10 minutes with a
sharpening stone, which you can
do, but most people don't
have the patience for it.
One last thing.
The European knives have a
20 degree angle to them.
The combination east west knives
have a 15 degree angle.
So if you sharpen a $200 Gyuto
knife with a traditional
electric sharpener, you'll
ruin the edge.
So Chef's Choice did come out
with a model that'll do both,
which is kind of important.
The last thing I would say
that's really important is a
good 12-inch skillet,
and you want--
All-Clad still makes
the best skillet.
I would invest in an All-Clad.
So those are the three or four
things you definitely need.
AUDIENCE: Thanks, that's
a great answer.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So there are some times that
I search for recipes on
"America's Test Kitchen" and
I'll get results from "Cook's
Country," and realize that I
don't have a membership there,
and I didn't realize that
recipe was part of it.
Is there any work being
done to sort of--
CHRIS KIMBALL: Yes.
AUDIENCE: --give
me the-- yeah.
CHRIS KIMBALL: My head of IT
who has a notebook and a
pencil promises me by April.
We're rebuilding all the
infrastructure, all of our sites.
The problem is that we have
an outside vendor--
it's owned by Hearst--
that handles all of our
subscriptions and processing.
And for us to do this entirely
on our own, without some of
the things they offer,
is almost impossible.
So we've been waiting for
them to get up to speed.
So we're right in the middle
of the project.
It should be done by May, at
which point you can have
access to everything.
It'll be easier.
Because right now, if you go
to three of our different
sites, you have three different
passwords, three
different credit cards.
It's very complicated.
AUDIENCE: And then the
last one, sorry.
Is there going to be an app for
the Android for "America's
Test Kitchen," or any
of the others?
CHRIS KIMBALL: Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRIS KIMBALL: Yes.
Yes.
I can't part say no.
I wouldn't get out
of here alive.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So America's changed
since you went to university.
What have you learned from
outside of America and brought
in from the science
perspective?
CHRIS KIMBALL: Well, not
so much from a science
perspective, but I think what's
interesting is there's
been a restaurant revolution
in the
last 30 years, obviously.
And home cooking hasn't
changed much, really.
It's starting to, in
the last two years.
Nothing goes into our magazines
unless we survey it.
We ask you what you want.
It's that old story.
In 1985, I was owned in part by
"The New Yorker." And so I
had an office at "The
New Yorker's"
building, and Bill Shawn--
William Shawn was the
editor back then, as
some of you may remember.
And Si Newhouse took Mr. Shawn
out for lunch at the Four
Seasons and said, Mr. Shawn, how
do you determine what your
readers want to read?
And Mr. Shawn said, I don't.
And Mr. Newhouse said,
what do you mean?
And he said, well, I just put
things in the magazine that I
want to read, and I assume
my readers have the
same tastes I do.
He was fired four
months later.
And my answer to that is we
only put things in the
magazine that you tell us you
want, because we don't take
advertising.
So we found in the last two
years that what you want is
starting to change.
That being said, I have
to say two things.
The top 10 rated recipes of all
time out of 7,000 recipes
we've rated-- we rate
every week--
two of them are green
bean casserole.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
CHRIS KIMBALL: Somebody here
makes green bean casserole.
Statistically, it
has to be true.
I don't know why, but they do.
And so what's starting to happen
now is techniques-- not
necessarily science,
but techniques--
I mean, stir fry used to be
ethnic at one time, right?
Which is ridiculous,
but it makes sense.
Small pieces of food cook
really quickly.
It's very variable.
It got incorporated into the
American repertoire fast.
Now all the things coming from
different parts of the world
that do make sense for American
home cooking, and
they are coming in.
And I would think in the next
five to eight years, you'll
see a huge change in American
home cooking.
It's just starting, but it
hasn't happened yet.
People are still making that
dried out lasagna, but that's
really changing.
I would suggest that my favorite
book currently is
Ottolenghi's "Plenty." I just
got "Jeruslaem." I've tried a
couple things.
I've cooked about half of the
recipes in that, because, you
know, the Ottoman Empire was
in the spice trade, on the
spice routes.
They had 85 to 90 different
spices.
Northern Europe had
a dozen spices.
"The Joy of Cooking" originally
had 15 spices.
So there are ways of combining
flavors, there are techniques
that we have never used here,
because we're mostly northern
European style cooking,
mostly.
And there's a lot that's
going to come in.
So I think it's going to change
completely, and I think
people's experience
with food through
restaurants has also changed.
They know what saag
paneer is now.
I still don't want to make it at
home, but many people in my
kitchen do.
But no, it's going to change.
AUDIENCE: So at the beginning
of your articles, you have
this description of what
you're going for.
We want a tender crust
or whatever.
So where does that preference
come from?
CHRIS KIMBALL: Well, the
question is, we have to pick a
lane for a story.
And so we survey and ask
what people want.
But at some point, it depends
on what we've done before.
We have to come to it with a
different point of view.
But you can do chewy chocolate
chip cookies, or you can do
crispy chocolate chip cookies,
and one's not
better than the other.
So it's mostly what you say, and
it's also our tastes, and
whether we think we can
add some value,
because it's a new direction.
It's something different.
Sometimes we'll go back and do
a story we did 10 years ago,
because we found out actually
it's not as good as it should
be, like pumpkin pie,
or creme brulee.
But it's mostly just a function
of listening to what
you guys want.
AUDIENCE: OK, sorry, one more,
since I'm a new cook.
So the trouble I always have
is doubling recipes.
I always assume that if I need
to double it for whatever
reason, like a sauce or
whatever, that I literally
double every single ingredient
I see, which, yeah, OK.
So are there certain things,
or a key, or something you
should use like never double
your flour, or only do that
amount and a quarter
or something?
CHRIS KIMBALL: Savory
versus baking.
Savory, a few things
to watch out for.
Don't double the heat
or the spices.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
CHRIS KIMBALL: Because
you hold off and then
taste as you go.
But that's really a problem.
Secondly, liquid.
Sometimes in a stew, if you're
going to triple a stew, you
don't need triple the liquid.
So that's something you
should look at.
The other thing is in baking,
as you double a recipe, then
the pan size doesn't
necessarily-- you need a
different pan size.
And you may end up with a
thicker, or more depth to the
cake, or whatever you're doing,
so the cooking time's
going to be off.
If you're going to create
something bigger, you tend to
lower the oven temperature by
25 degrees, so it's going to
have to cook a little
longer, so you don't
overcook the outside.
In general, baking is tough.
And also, when you mix things
together, like you're creaming
butter or mixing things
together, if you quadruple a
recipe, when you mix it, you're
going to over mix it to
get everything mixed together.
For example, when you make
brownies, it always says, or
should say, streaks of flour
left in the batter?
Well, I know what you do,
because I do the same thing.
I'm going like, hey, there
are still streaks of
flour in the batter.
This can't be right.
So you keep going
a couple more.
Well, what happens is you
develop gluten as a result.
The brownies rise a little bit
more, because there's more
structure, but they
turn out cakey.
Not that good.
So when you have double the
recipe or quadruple the
recipe, you end up mixing more,
there's more agitation,
and you end up--
so very often in the test
kitchen, we'll just maybe
double it, maybe not, and just
make more than one batch.
But baking is particularly
difficult.
AUDIENCE: So what about
cider-braised pork steaks,
like a recipe like that?
CHRIS KIMBALL: That's
not a problem.
AUDIENCE: You can double that?
CHRIS KIMBALL: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: In the magazine where
the people write in with
questions, there was once
a question about using
California bay laurel leaves
instead of [INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS KIMBALL: Oh
yeah, Turkish.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And the answer was that it
wasn't worth the price to use
California.
But the thing is that we're
here in California.
A lot of people have those
trees in their
yard, so it's free.
And so I was wondering, can
you use the bay that grows
around here, and do you use a
different amount, or is it
just one for--
CHRIS KIMBALL: I do remember
that letter.
It was a few years ago.
I think we decided that we
preferred, actually, the
California, I think.
But yeah, sure.
You can use them.
I mean, my pet peeve is-- and
I argue this all the time--
you know recipes, you're doing
a stew for 12 people, and it
says add a sprig of thyme?
Are you kidding me?
I mean, I don't know, maybe the
French had particularly
pungent thyme.
But I mean, a sprig of thyme
isn't going to do anything.
You're never going to
know it's there.
And sometimes I feel the same
way about bay leaves--
I always add an extra one.
So yeah, you can use it, sure.
But I think one thing I've
learned is, also, towards the
end of cooking, I mean, unless
it's baking, but if it's a
stew, a soup, or whatever,
taste it.
People just assume--
my 22-year-old loves to cook--
and she'll just follow the
recipe and won't taste
it and serve it.
And, you know, it needs salt,
it needs something else, a
little vinegar.
But at the end of cooking, fresh
herbs are best added at
the end, grated or minced
ginger, garlic.
There's lots of little things
you can add at the end of
cooking-- vinegar,
lemon juice--
to get the balance right.
And so that's the most important
part of cooking,
other than cleaning up, is
the last five minutes.
And adding those things
at the end.
And there's also secret
ingredients.
Years ago, someone in my office
mentioned pomegranate
molasses, and I made fun of
them, because it's a stupid
hard to find ingredient.
Now it's not hard to find.
That's one of the things I have
at my disposal when I'm
cooking, just to get
the balance right.
It's a little sweet,
a little sour.
So it's that last minute that's
really important.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned about
thinking that there's
new spices, and that kind
of thing, maybe some new
techniques coming from
around the world.
What about just new approaches,
and I guess more
technology in the kitchen?
CHRIS KIMBALL: Well,
sure, yes.
We're doing a pressure cooker
book right now.
That's actually going to be
huge, because it's fast.
It's not a slow cooker,
it's a fast cooker.
You can make the world's best
chicken stock in 15 minutes.
You can make risotto
in 15 minutes.
And also, a pressure cooker
turns out great food.
So that's going to be big.
Everyone's talking
about sous-vide.
AUDIENCE: That's getting
to be affordable now.
CHRIS KIMBALL: There's a $450
one we liked, which is--
I mean, the problem with that
is, money is one issue, but
then what do you do with it?
I'm sorry, I've gotten down to
small things now, because
these big things, you've
got to take it out.
But yeah, sous-vide is fine.
Although, I have to say, the
problem with sous-vide for me
is I like to chew my food.
And I find, like, if you've
ever had a turkey sandwich
made with sous-vide turkey,
it feels kind of wet.
And so as a friend of mine
said about turkey at
Thanksgiving, he says he likes
overcooked white meat, because
that's the tradition
at his house.
And he said that's why
God invented gravy.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
CHRIS KIMBALL: Well, who wants
gravy and a particularly moist
piece of white meat?
It doesn't work.
So I don't know.
Yeah, it's a great way of
cooking, but I don't think
that's going to be in
everybody's kitchen.
But I think the pressure cooker
is probably one of
those things that will be.
So thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]